Bonjour !
Bonjour ! Bonjour. Bonjour...
*crachat*
*fracas*
Oui ! Très bien.
Bienvenue à Bétatown ! Bonne journée !
On recommence ?
Les enceintes fonctionnent...
Allez, encore une fois
Bonjour Monsieur ! Un petit test d'effort ?
Bonjour Monsieur ! Testez vos réflexes.
*acouphènes*
*soupir*
-Oui bonjour ?
-Bonjour,
J'ai rendez-vous avec Mme Philibert des ressources humaines
Très bien
-ALLÔ ALLÔ ?
ALLÔ ?!
Allo allo?
Bien.. Le téléphone fonctionne
Bien..
Vous êtes monsieur?
Alors j'ai trois noms
Barmigeli
Sissoko
Lantier
Lantier! Voilà ce nom fonctionne
ALLÔ! Oui madame Philibert, j'ai monsieur Lantier à l'accueil.
*on toque*
Entrez
Sortez
Entrez sortez
Entrez
Très bien, cette porte fonctionne
Asseyez-vous
Levez-vous
Asseyez-vous. Très bien, cette chaise fonctionne
Est-ce que vous avez apporté un CV monsieur Lantier?
Alors monsieur Lantier si vous êtes ici c'est que vous n'êtes pas ailleurs.
Et si vous n'êtes pas ailleurs c'est que vous êtes...?
C'est que vous êtes...?
Ici?
Très bien!
Donc vos réponses fonctionnent.
Parlez-moi de vos principales qualités pour ce poste.
Euh... *se râcle la gorge*
J'suis fonceur.
J'ai pas besoin de tester 10 fois quelque chose avant de me lancer.
Quitte à prendre un risque
J'adore ça les risques. C'est ce qui me maintient en vie, vous voyez?
*en rigolant*Oui je vois très bien. Monsieur Lantier, je suis désolée mais vous n'avez pas le poste, merci.
Ah..
Monsieur Lantier. Euh... vous n'avez pas le poste pour les raisons que vous savez..
Vous comprenez?
Oui oui, j'ai bien compris.
Monsieur Lantier! En fait je ne peux pas vous donner ce travail parce que ici, cette entreprise si vous voulez,
C'est comme une sorte de.. une tarte, voilà c'est une tarte, au quetsche, et vous vous êtes une fraise..
Vous êtes une fraise qui arrive et qui plonge dans cette tarte    -*en l'interrompant*Madame Philibert?
Votre refus fonctionne..
Merci
La DRH fonctionne
*rembobine*
*dans le dictaphone* "La DRH fonctionne
Le dictaphone aussi
*chuchote* Je t'aime
Moi aussi je t'aime
Donc notre amour fonctionne c'est ça?
Pour qui tu me prends? C'était pas un test!
J'te laisse travailler
"premier sketch youtube en tant qu'auteur"
"c'est un sketch d'anticipation, puisque..."